-Hey, Mister DJ, put a record on.
I wanna dance with my baby.
♪♪
-♪ One, two, three, four ♪
-♪ Hey, Mister DJ ♪
♪ Put a record on ♪
♪ I wanna dance with my baby ♪
♪ And when the music starts ♪
♪ I never want to stop ♪
♪ It's gonna drive me crazy ♪
-♪ Music, music, music, music ♪
♪ Music, music, music, music, music ♪
-♪ One, two, three, four ♪
♪ Music makes the people come together ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Music makes the bourgeoisie ♪
♪ And the rebel ♪
♪♪
-♪ Don't think of yesterday ♪
♪ And I don't look at the clock ♪
♪ I like to boogie-woogie ♪
♪ Uh, uh ♪
♪ It's like riding on the wind ♪
♪ And it never goes away ♪
♪ Touches everything I'm in ♪
♪ Got to have it every day, here we go ♪
-♪ Music... ♪
-♪ Music, music, music ♪ -♪ Two, three, four ♪
♪ Music ♪ -♪ Music ♪
-♪ Makes the people ♪ -♪ Makes the people ♪
-♪ Come together ♪ -♪ Together ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Music ♪ -♪ Music ♪
-♪ Makes the bourgeoisie ♪
♪ And the rebel ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]